so the bottom line for me as I watched
this interview was I was curious why he
did the interview and I think people ask
me you know when I when I plan to do
this I got a lot of messages because I
worked on The View
do you think it's smart to do these
I do I do think it's smart to do these
um I think that if you're going to do an
interview with somebody that you that
sees the world differently where you
think there may be a little bit of a
trap or a little bit of you must do them
in person you must do them in person and
you must assure that they're not edited
okay so it has to just be live it has to
be something that rolls out and that's
your way of having some control and
autonomy over what gets said meaning
that what what you say actually gets
heard by the audience and not cropped up
and whatever it's very important to do
these you cannot expose some of this
stuff without exposing it in their own
realm and these conversations are very
important because Big Ideas win
Big Ideas always win Common Sense comes
out on top
facts matter and all of those things
will always rise to the surface if you
know how to handle yourself if you're a
good debater and you're facing someone
whose goal is to tear at some of that
stuff so you must you must go into these
spaces and stand tall and speak your
mind
um and I I think that people who
people who support Andrew Tade and
people who are really familiar with his
long-form content watch this and felt
and understood the importance of why he
was there
I also think Pierce Morgan made a few
big mistakes in this interview by
getting emotional
and by you know buying into what some of
those short clips say and by caring so
much about the emotions that people feel
when they hear someone's content
it's just we can't endorse this nation
of babies anymore we really just can't
and we have to build a society where you
turn something on and you disagree and
that's okay and you you're not deflated
by it and you're not injured by it and
you don't feel the need to censor that
person you just pick your head up and
you walk away and you say I disagree end
of story and it needs to start young
parents raise your kids to be the kind
of people who aren't just deflated
by dissent
we're going to get back to the chat
Tyler got a few here so let's go we had
a soldier for God gave 10 bucks and said
uh I repeat Ben Shapiro quote Piers you
stand on the bones of the dead children
it's Sandy Hook as if they don't care
about the kids if they disagree with you
on anything
I had another one uh let's see Jesus
Diaz gave 20 bucks said Jedediah Tyler
is it possible that peers and others
interview Tate intentionally in order to
expose sanity to the mainstream example
they want more men to find him and think
like him because alpha males are
endangered
kind of like a reverse psychology uh and
Sharon gave 10 bucks that as a mother of
two amazing girls and sister to four
brothers and a child of the 60s I give
thanks Andrew is talking so much truth
in this time of Madness strong men now
more than ever are needed
yeah so that's part of that pierce
question I don't think he does it for
that reason I think Pierce Morgan is an
inquisitive person by nature which is a
good thing
um I think he I think that Andrew Tate
has blown up I mean the guy is just
everywhere and I think it's he knows
that people are going to watch and it's
a good interview and it will be a good
exchange
um he says at some point that he has I
don't know how many children he has a
few children but I don't know how many
are Sons he mentions sons that watch
Andrew so I think parents have a
curiosity about this content because
their children have been aware of it and
absorbing it and oftentimes absorbing
the short form content which is out of
context and they want to dig into that
to kind of get to the heart of who this
guy really is and I you know I felt that
way when I first saw that first final
message I was like okay well I'm looking
at this short these short clips so I'm
looking at this final who is this guy
who is this guy really he's an
interesting figure he anyone who's had
this this big of an impact on culture in
one way or another is an interesting
figure and I think there is some
Intrigue about what he really stands for
and I think it's been very important for
him to do content like this where he can
clarify and again I would say to him
you have he has acknowledged many times
that when he made a lot of those videos
he wasn't as famous and now they're out
there and you have to be conscious of
what you say when you when you have
spotlights on you like this that's all
correct I will say no matter what you
could get clipped today tomorrow and
they can make you you could be like
someone that rescues cats from shelters
and they'll make you out to be like
somebody who kills cats if they want to
you know they will twist and distort and
edit and delete and combine I mean that
can all still happen but there is a
degree of responsibility that comes with
Fame I think he's owned up to that I
think it's been truly fascinating to see
him in these interviews
um and and just see the juxtaposition of
the two people so I do believe that
Pierce Morgan had an agenda to to figure
out who this guy really was but I also
think that he tends to um he agrees with
some things but the things he disagrees
with he really does he wanted to rip in
there
um and I just don't think that was
accomplished
um I thought it was a fantastic exchange
of ideas and I do think these interviews
are very important though anything else
in the chat yeah there's one more that
kind of touches on what you just said uh
I think this interview makes him look uh
I think this interview makes him look
good and not what people thought of him
at first do you think after this he will
be unbanned
no
I don't
I don't because I think that they need
to make an example out of him
um I think they they succeeded in doing
that and I think again I don't think
that banning was for Tate Tate's gonna
go he's on Rumble now he's got a bunch
of people watching him he has his own
website people subscribe to content
they're getting his content he's getting
invited to do big interviews
um he did that long five-hour interview
with pbd he did this interview he's
going to do a bunch of podcast
interviews I'm sure his message is not
going to be compromised but I think it
that was created to send a message to
the little guy again I will always tell
you the system targets the little guy
who doesn't have the outside platform
they want to scare people into
submission they want to scare people who
make videos into saying well these
topics are off limits so as long as you
don't touch those you're safe so then
they want people to say oh well I'm just
going to stay safe I'm not going to
touch any of this stuff and what that
does is it limits debate it limits
discussion it limits the free exchange
of ideas and it squashes free thinking
people who then don't hear the other
side and aren't exposed to to a flood of
ideas where they can then say how do I
really feel and it creates stewards of
the system so the little guy will always
be the Target and I think they needed to
to in this case go after the big guy to
send a message to a little guy they're
not going to walk that back
um and and I don't and I think that the
thought police is is on Full display
everywhere right now so I would just
encourage people everywhere when you see
something like this you can't get quiet
don't stay safe
in the safe topics
say what you feel say what you feel and
make your voice heard and stand by what
you said and listen to what other people
say with open ears and an open mind with
the idea that maybe you'll be convinced
of something but fight like it's your
last breath for that for that exchange
of ideas and for the protection of those
spaces where those ideas get exchanged
because without that
what do we turn into really what do we
turn into oh these are your approved
topics I mean I mean where are we going
the way of Animal Farm and Brave New
World who wants to live in that not me
probably not you so in order to not live
in it you have to not succumb to it
um and the way you don't succumb to it
is you speak your mind
the way that Andrew taped it agree with
him or not guy spoke his mind and he's
still talking
I want to thank you all for being with
us today I the rest of the week is like
a little weird schedule was so I can't
tell you when because I need to wait for
some confirms but we will be here we do
have some really good guests coming up
um and I'm grateful for your time as
always and I will see you back either
tomorrow or Thursday
just check my check my Instagram I'll
let you know subscribe like love you see
you soon if you want to watch the full
episode you're going to click right here
and if you want to ask me a question one
on one you want to do a one-on-one
FaceTime with a group of your friends
whatever you want you need to download
manect right now click right here and
let's get talking
foreign
[Music]